After we connect the client in
the onStart, it takes some time for
the connection to happen.
And when it does,
the onConnected callback will fire.
This is the meat of our app.
We've connected to location services,
so we should be
able to get the last location
from the fused location provider.
And if we do get something,
then we can read the latitude and
the longitude from it.
We convert that to a string and
then load it into the appropriate
text field as you can see here.
Now, remember, all this will happen
if last location is not null.
So, here I've just checked if
mLastLocation is not equal to null,
then I will do all of this.
Because if it was equal to null,
then getting the latitude and
getting the longitude
might produce an error.